man i had a clever ass way that i was
gonna say how uh much money the special
made and i already did that show on
instagram i feel like a [ __ ] fraud
come on i'm not i feel like do you want
me to do much why did you save the good
stuff for us why do you always give it
to instagram because i was too excited
come on
okay should i try to be a good actor
yeah do it dawg
let's see if i can pull it hey you're
making money off comedy now this movie's
next that's facts okay ready here it is
um
what's up guys uh you know a lot of
you've been reaching out come on son let
me get into
all right come on let me be serious okay
hey guys um
what
you ain't even trying you through that
one throw it out i'll get this one your
motivation in this scenario
what is it hey guys are you in
superheroes i like this one
let me get into it let me do this like
actually ready okay
hey guys i like it i like it i like it
i'm not i didn't even start it yeah gosh
what's up guys
um listen a lot of you guys have been
reaching out uh to see how i did with
the special you know we just got the
numbers back and um a lot of you've been
asking you know if i made my money back
and uh i did not
uh
i made three times
my money back
i'm clapping for the statistic and the
acting is that good i know i liked it
bro i thought that was pretty good
anyway listen for everybody asking i i
do appreciate you all reaching out and
we did we made three times the [ __ ]
money we spent on it which is
crazy and it's still available for
another i guess 10 days so if you guys
haven't gotten it just yet you missed it
for 10 more days available at the
andrews trolls.com so go buy that [ __ ]
and tell your friends and uh and if
you're not sure yeah just search andrew
schultz on twitter and watch the
feedback it's [ __ ]
overwhelmingly positive yeah that was
crazy that was cool that was really cool
and it was cool that
we me i know we spoke about this before
but like it was cool that we made a an
event
and yes
and everybody we had literally hundreds
of thousands of people watching it at
the same time yeah that was [ __ ] fire
and it was great to see the reaction at
the same time it literally felt like
watching tv
ten years ago like remember breaking bad
was on and everybody's reacting breaking
bad or even early days of guy code yeah
where it's like you could see what
people are reacting to people reacting
to the exact joke they're talking about
it and it was just a [ __ ] awesome
moment and it's not like a special that
just kind of gets lost on a streamer
where you go oh eventually i'll get to
that yeah eventually i'll watch you know
what i mean like i've been saying i'll
eventually watch drag carmichael's i'm
gay again special for [ __ ]
literally for a month i'm like
eventually i'm gonna watch how he's gay
again and i just hadn't
because no because he's gay again like i
said this yeah
i know
we watching this again no but it's but
but slower for white people now okay
okay
white people i'm gay
i watched the first time gay for black
people and breakfast club but i also
will watch the white one okay no you
left out his home movie special he said
he was bi
to his sister or whatever the [ __ ] did
you come out three times it came out
three times you didn't even come out
once
yeah you got to come on you're special
can i try it again yeah guys i know a
lot of y'all been reaching out to see if
i suck dicks as well
and uh we are getting divorced
not for the money
[Laughter]
completely different
but uh but no i'm [ __ ] so stoked and
i'm so goddamn grateful and you know i'm
saying this on on the post but i really
mean it like like i don't have a
publicist right like what we do is we
have uh a group of friends who have a
unique set of skills no i feel like
[ __ ] liam neeson but like but like no
we have a group of friends and we have a
[ __ ] army of people that support what
we do and it's awesome that i can go on
all these podcasts and they can
literally lend the platform yeah and
then they're famous [ __ ] people like
rogan and charlemagne
and the rock
yeah and shout out to all them that did
that and uh yeah it was just awesome
that it's a [ __ ] great feeling i'm so
proud of my brother man i was so [ __ ]
proud of you and i've said this to you a
couple times but i'ma say it again i
have seen this special four times at the
taping i watched it twice to give you
notes and i watched it a seventh time
sunday and it still got genuine laughs
out of me and that every time i laughed
i was like wow i have seen this seven
times and i'm still [ __ ] laughing and
that's an accomplishment and to what you
said about making a moment a comedy
watch party i've never done and it was
so [ __ ] great yes like we have fight
night watch parties but i don't really
give a [ __ ] about fight night yeah yeah
so cool i'll be there we'll hang out
we'll have fun but comedy a bunch of
people who love stand up who are
watching somebody they're a fan of all
just sharing that moment was so [ __ ]
cool yeah and i
truly believe
you changed comedy twice
okay and i'm gonna say this and
everybody's gonna think that i'm sucking
your dick because you're my brother and
that's only half true i'm also not wrong
so i can
[Laughter]
you weren't the first guy to ever put
clips on youtube yeah listen in india
they were doing that but in america we
had hollywood and we're all playing this
game you did it and then we all saw oh
[ __ ] this can get you everything you
want instead of having to play the
hollywood game let's just do this and
now you cannot scroll instagram for five
minutes without seeing 25 stand-up clips
that's you yeah i hope what this did and
louie put out to specials on his own but
i think what we thought was i know i
thought this well yeah when you're doing
[ __ ] arenas you can put out a special
on your own when you have your own tv
show you can put out a special on your
own right you are proven theaters is
huge and you're doing theaters and
that's amazing and you will do arenas
but i think we're looking at that like
oh you don't have to be one of the most
famous people yeah on earth for it to
put out your own special you just have
to have a devoted group of people who
really rock with you and they rock with
the type of content you put out yes yeah
yeah yeah that that [ __ ] was and so i
yeah i think she was cool i think you
might change comedy twice bro it's hey
listen i'm not gonna lie this [ __ ] is a
lot of [ __ ] work yeah you guys know
it
it ain't this is not like putting out a
youtube special yes it's not it is a lot
of [ __ ] work
and i i get why there are companies that
do this for a living
because this [ __ ] ain't fun yeah now
that being said it is incredibly
gratifying i i hope you guys also feel
that way when it becomes successful and
uh now and if there's any comics out
there like like we've always done is you
have any questions we [ __ ] got you
hollered us we'll tell you guys how to
do it and i'll be like very candid if i
think you you can do this successfully
because there probably is a number of
people or followers that will dictate
how much support you'll actually get but
it was it was [ __ ] cool and i'm super
stoked and i'm grateful and i'm [ __ ]
yeah i feel really uh uh sounds so gay
but i feel really like full
does that make sense yeah yeah yeah yeah
yep in both ways you look at it it's a
little gay yeah
full though no maybe you just ate a lot
of dick oh yeah yeah
that that that awesome
sound good man feel that you should
enjoy this [ __ ] moment take your lap
yeah yeah and
uh keep buying it we still got time
that's right yeah yeah and it's yours
forever when you get it by the way i
just want to let you know hit me up i'll
send you a link for 10 bucks yeah man oh
oh wait i'm gonna beat
because uh shots of a [ __ ] bet
online is giving you a free 15 bet every
single time damn if you buy the special
you get a free 15 better bet online
that's the best deal on the
[ __ ] planet and get their money
take their [ __ ] money
i'm supposed to be partnering with them
take their ass
take their put it on crazy parlay drain
their [ __ ] bank accounts send that
[ __ ] over here that's what i'm doing
film the best i'm doing the craziest
parlay okay what are you doing i don't
know i'm thinking like 25 30 teams my
goal is to figure out exactly how much
you made and then place a bet that would
make me more money so you have to hope
it works out because nothing would drive
you crazier than if i made more money
off your special than you did oh that
would that would drive me [ __ ]
awesome i'm gonna match whatever bet you
make you have to put your bet on like
the craziest thing that there's no way
it could [ __ ] happen like yes a woman
on a train in india not getting raped
like is it what are the what are the
odds i don't know why that's necessary
i don't know why that's necessary what
are the odds on that okay well let's see
like how many rapists yeah
that's a good thing dude there's double
bet potential rape soda trains yeah
samuel jackson it's just samuel jackson
in the next volleyball if we're talking
one just one single race
but if there's like a group of guys and
one girl okay yeah odds are in my face
indians have like 50 words for rape do
you know that oh in their culture you're
making a call back to something that
wasn't recorded miles was teaching us
about things that we try to forget
immediately after
he was talking about how eskimos know
all this is how racist miles is he's
like listen
eskimos know 50 different types of
whites you know i'm trying to get to
that
that was amazing there's all white mixed
white
aryan white it's my favorite
all of them um but yeah you were saying
that they know all that yeah exactly
yeah yeah
anyway well thank you guys so much for
supporting and uh and that yeah it's
really awesome let's talk about
something i don't know a couple
questions okay got to ask you this you
didn't have an answer before okay is
this the proudest moment of your career
yes now yes amazing yeah congratulations
second i remember a couple years ago
things were going well you bought alex a
rolex for how hard he had been working
yeah shifty really killed himself for
this
so what are you getting shifty bro oh
that's a great question i think yeah i
think you sh
right like if you made three extra money
you got to give him 3x what you gave
alex gift wise
i think that's a good bet it feels
proportionate first of all
everybody got to watch
i just want to point that out it wasn't
just alex yeah i got i got one i've got
to watch mark gotta watch miles got to
watch what a champion
he wasn't hearing he got burgers he
wasn't here a year yet he's got
birkenstocks he wasn't here a year yet
you know what i mean you got to put in
the time i got to know that you're a
part of the organization okay but
something's coming his way don't worry